This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Each day teachers all over the world try to explain new ideas to their students. Sometimes it goes well. The teacher conveys information, the students absorb it. But many times things get stuck. Students get frustrated and so do their teachers. The transmission of ideas gets bogged down in a morass of failed expectations. I remember an exchange I had with my own father. I must have been around ten. He was trying to teach me a math concept, the order of operations, division before subtraction, multiplication before addition.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedanta。每天，全世界的老师都在努力向学生解释新概念。有时进展顺利，老师传授知识，学生吸收知识。但很多时候，事情会陷入僵局。学生感到沮丧，老师也一样。知识的传递陷入了期望落空的泥潭。我记得我曾与父亲有过一次交流。那时我大概十岁左右。他试图教我一个数学概念，即运算顺序：先除后减，先乘后加。
I didn't get it. He thought it ought to be easy. He got frustrated, I felt stupid. The worst part was that all the psychological turmoil got us nowhere. At the end of the day, he had failed to teach me something he knew, and I had failed to learn something I could have mastered. In fact, I might have internalized the wrong lessons that I was bad at math or that my father thought poorly of me. What does he think? Why am I so bad? Is he mad?
我没听懂。他觉得这应该很简单。他感到沮丧，我感到自己很笨。最糟糕的是，所有的心理折磨并没有让我们取得任何进展。到最后，他没能教会我他所掌握的知识，而我也没能学会本可以掌握的东西。事实上，我可能内化了错误的教训，认为自己不擅长数学，或者认为父亲看不起我。他在想什么？为什么我这么差劲？他在生气吗？
I can't forget that. Disappointing, can I show him? Can I make my dad proud? Today we explore an innovative idea about how we learn. It'll take us from a dolphin exhibit in Hawaii to a top teaching hospital in New York. It's about one method to quiet the noise in our heads, the sort of clutter that can turn learning into a minefield of misery. One evening in the early 1960s, after putting her kids to bed, a young mother sat in her living room and read a small technical manual on dolphin training.
我无法忘记那一刻。令人失望，我能向他证明自己吗？我能让父亲感到骄傲吗？今天，我们将探讨一个关于我们如何学习的创新理念。它将带我们从夏威夷的海豚展览馆走进纽约的一家顶级教学医院。这是一种让大脑安静下来的方法，这种杂乱的思绪会将学习变成一片充满痛苦的雷区。20世纪60年代初的一个晚上，一位年轻的母亲在哄孩子入睡后，坐在客厅里读了一本关于海豚训练的小型技术手册。
The ideas in it seemed new and strange. The woman felt an unexpected thrill. As she thumbed through the typewritten pages, she saw for herself a future she had never imagined. It opened a door for me. I saw a whole new game there. How to control behavior, how to build behavior, how to teach skills, all of that. With a little set of clear cut roles that would work with anything. This is Karen Pryor.
书中的观点看起来既新奇又陌生。这位女士感到一种意想不到的兴奋。当她翻阅那些打字机打印出来的页面时，她看到了一个自己从未想象过的未来。它为我打开了一扇门。我在那里看到了一个全新的游戏。如何控制行为，如何建立行为，如何教授技能，所有这些。通过一套清晰明确、适用于任何情况的规则。这就是Karen Pryor。
I'm a biologist and I'm also a writer. Karen is now in her 80s and living in Boston. But back in the early 60s she was in Hawaii, raising three kids, while her husband poured his energy into a grand venture. He was building Sea Life Park, the island's first aquarium and marine entertainment venue. It was his startup, not Carrons. I wasn't involved in the park at all except to maybe give a dinner party for potential investors, you know, that kind of thing. There was a lot at stake. Big dreams and big money had been poured into the project and the timeline for the ground opening was tight.
我是一名生物学家，也是一名作家。Karen现在80多岁了，住在波士顿。但在60年代初，她住在夏威夷，抚养着三个孩子，而她的丈夫则将精力投入到一项宏大的事业中。他正在建造海洋生物公园（Sea Life Park），这是岛上第一个水族馆和海洋娱乐场所。那是他的创业项目，而不是Karen的。我根本没有参与公园的事务，除了可能为潜在投资者举办晚宴之类的活动。当时赌注很大。巨大的梦想和巨额资金投入到了这个项目中，开业的时间表非常紧迫。
When the concrete had set in the huge artificial pools, collectors were sent out to capture wild dolphins. The next challenge was to train the animals. The park needed a dolphin trainer, a profession that didn't really exist. The only trainers that were around in that time, in the early 60s, were sea lion trainers from the circus. And they were pretty abusive. Now, the way we've come to think about marine parks
当巨大的水池混凝土凝固后，采集员被派去捕捉野生海豚。接下来的挑战是训练这些动物。公园需要一名海豚训练师，这在当时并不是一个真正的职业。在60年代初，当时唯一的训练师是马戏团的海狮训练师。他们相当粗暴。现在，我们对海洋公园的看法在过去50年里发生了很大变化。让动物表演杂技受到谴责。从野外捕捉鲸鱼和海豚是非法的。但在60年代，限制较少，社会规范也不同。如果说公园及其方法属于那个时代，那么Karen即将学到的课程却是永恒的。公园获得的那本由一位心理学研究生编写的小手册承诺，只要遵循书中描述的技术，任何人都可以成为海豚训练师。
has changed a lot in the last 50 years. It's frowned upon to get animals to perform tricks. It's illegal to capture whales and dolphins from the wild. But in the 60s, restrictions were looser and social norms were different. If the park and its methods were of a different time, the lessons Karen was to learn were timeless. The little manual the park had obtained, written by a graduate student in psychology, promised that anyone could be a dolphin trainer, as long as the techniques it described were followed.
Karen的丈夫雇佣了一个三人团队。在绝望中，Karen的丈夫向她求助。她对自然界很感兴趣，小时候她就记住了附近每一种蝴蝶的拉丁学名。在康奈尔大学学习时，她修读了学校提供的所有自然历史课程。昆虫学、鸟类学、古生物学、地质学。但海洋生物学并不在她的首选名单上。所以我说不，我真的做不到。我有三个小孩。我不想为我丈夫工作。他已经够忙了，而且我觉得这也不会有什么好结果。
Karen's husband hired a team of three people. In desperation, Karen's husband turned to her. She was interested in the natural world, as a little girl she learned the Latin name of every butterfly in her neighborhood. While studying at Cornell, she'd taken all the courses the school offered in natural history. And tomology for insects or mythology for birds, paleontology for fossils, geology for rocks. But marine biology wasn't high on the list. So I said no, I really couldn't do that. I have three little children. I didn't want to go to work for my husband. He had enough to do, and I think that would
但他还是说服我至少读读那本手册。而那本手册及其蕴含的理念，在Karen心中点燃了火花。我必须试一试。Karen在手册中看到的是一种在过去几十年里在心理学界引发巨大争论的行为理论。它的影响深远，尤其是在教育领域。让我们花点时间回顾一下那段历史。在20世纪初，关于人们为何会有某种行为的一种主流观点来自西格蒙德·弗洛伊德。
work out very well anyway. But he persuaded me to at least read the manual. And that manual, the ideas it held, sparked something inside of Karen. I just had to try it. What Karen saw in the manual was a theory of behavior that it ignited a great debate in psychology in the preceding decades. Its implications were far reaching, especially in the field of education. Let's take a moment to look at that history. In the early 20th century, one dominant view of why people behave the way they do came
弗洛伊德关注的是促使人们做事的深层潜在动机，以及你必须如何深入挖掘那些往往无法触及的人类心理过程来了解一个人。这是心理学家Barry Schwartz。弗洛伊德认为，人们受到非常强烈的动机驱动，其中许多与性有关，许多与父母关系有关，这些动机是如此不可接受，以至于人们将它们排除在意识之外。潜意识，一切都隐藏在大脑的一个小黑盒子里。
from Sigmund Freud. Freud was all about the sort of the deep underlying motivations that got people to do stuff and how you had to plum the depths of your often inaccessible human psychological processes to figure people out. This is psychologist Barry Schwartz. Freud had this view that people were driven by really intense motives, many of them sexual, many of them having to do with relations with their parents, that were so unacceptable that people kept them out of conscious awareness. The unconscious, it was all hidden away in a little black box in the brain.
大约在同一时间，俄罗斯生理学家伊万·巴甫洛夫做出了一个惊人的发现。在一个著名的实验中，他证明了通过正确的触发因素，可以训练动物表现出非自愿的行为。他称之为经典条件反射。巴甫洛夫研究的是他所谓的反射，事实上他称之为心理反射。狗在嘴里有食物时会流口水，这是它们的本能。但如果你先发出一个声音，然后给它们食物，它们就会开始对这个声音产生流口水的反应。这个实验非常出名，甚至还拍摄了纪录片。
Around the same time, the Russian physiologist Ivan Pavlov made a remarkable discovery. In an experiment that became famous, he showed that with the right triggers, an animal could be trained to display involuntary behaviors. He called it classical conditioning. Pavlov was studying what he called reflexes, and in fact he called them psychic reflexes. So dogs salivate when you put food in their mouths and they're built to do that. But if you sound a tone and then give them food, they start salivating to the tone. The experiment has become so famous that documentaries have been made about it.
在把肉通过舱口送进去之前，他引入了一个与喂食完全无关的刺激物。一个滴答作响的节拍器。加入这个组合的是美国心理学家B.F.斯金纳。斯金纳和巴甫洛夫一样，对动物如何学习感兴趣，但他想探索有意识的行为。他最终提出了一种建立在巴甫洛夫理论之上，并完全摒弃了弗洛伊德理论的学说。斯金纳说，你不需要了解潜意识来弄清楚是什么让动物行动，也不需要了解它如何学习。你不需要所有这些深度，你不需要引用“理解内部发生了什么”。
Before passing meat through the hatch, he introduced a stimulus that was totally unrelated to feeding. A ticking metronome. Into this mix, Schema American. B.F. Schinner, like Ivan Pavlov, was interested in how animals learn, but he wanted to explore conscious behavior. He eventually came up with a theory that built on Pavlov and did away entirely with Freud. Skinner said, you don't need to understand the unconscious mind to figure out what makes an animal tick or to get it to learn something. You don't need all this depth, you don't need to, quote, understand what's going on inside,
只需要观察行为和环境如何相互作用就足够了。斯金纳认为，这一切其实都与奖励和惩罚有关，如果你能正确运用它们，你几乎可以让生物做任何你想让它们做的事。对于B.F.斯金纳和其他行为主义者来说，人类行为只关乎你能看到和测量到的东西，而改变行为的关键在于找到正确的激励措施。好的后果随之而来，你就会再次这样做；坏的后果随之而来，你就会停止这样做。B.F.斯金纳的理论变得非常流行。
it's enough just to look at how behavior and environment interact. And Skinner had this view that it was really all about rewards and punishments, that if you got them right, you could pretty much get organisms to do whatever you wanted them to do. For BF Skinner and other behaviorists, human behavior was only about what you could see and measure, and changing behavior was all about finding the right incentives. Good consequences follow and you'll do it again, bad consequences follow and you'll stop doing it. B.F. Skinner's theories became wildly popular.
他向挤满的演讲厅和摄制组展示了他的想法。他展示了一个他发明的盒子，并描述了他如何用它来训练鸟类。我们要用饥饿的鸽子，我们要给它们食物。他把一只鸽子放进盒子里。食物由一台小机器提供，它将一个食物托盘升到鸽子够得着的地方。鸽子可以通过空间里的一个开口获得食物。当托盘落下时，鸽子就吃不到了。
He presented his ideas to pack lecture halls and to film crews. He'd display a box he'd invented and describe how he used it with birds. We're going to use hungry pigeons and we're going to give them food. He put a pigeon into his box. And the food is presented with a little machine which lifts a tray of food within reach of the pigeon. Pigeon can get access to it through an opening in the space. And when the tray falls away, that pigeon can no longer eat.
鸽子很快学会了来到机器启动的地方。这是一个简单的例子，但很容易变得更复杂。也许鸽子必须啄一下按钮才能启动机器，或者转个圈。以食物为奖励，它可以学会很多东西。现在我们要尝试另一只鸽子，我会试着挑选出某种特定的行为模式，并使其成为这只鸟行为库中更频繁的一部分。
The pigeon quickly learns to come where the machine engages. It's a simple example, but it can easily be made more complex. Maybe the pigeon must pack at a button to engage the machine or turn in a circle. With food as a reward, it can be taught a lot. And we're going to try another pigeon now, and I will try to pick out some particular pattern of behavior and make it a more frequent part of the repertoire of the bird.
行为主义者还有另一个盒子来演示负强化。他把一只老鼠放进盒子里，盒子里有电流会导致它疼痛，但盒子里也有一个可以切断电流的杠杆。老鼠很快学会了直接走到杠杆前，在被放进盒子时关掉电流。B.F.斯金纳的观点是，如果你正确设置了激励和抑制因素，你可以让动物做它们通常不会做的事情。这些想法恰好是Karen Pryor那本小手册的核心。
The behaviorist had another box to demonstrate negative reinforcement. He'd put a rat into the box with an electric current that caused it pain, but the box also had a lever that could switch off the current. The rat quickly learned to go straight to the lever and turn off the electricity when it was placed inside the box. BF Skinner's point was that you can get animals to do things they wouldn't normally do if you set up the incentives and disincentives correctly. These ideas just happened to be front and center in Karen Pryor's little manual.
这是一本关于B.F.斯金纳所称的“操作性条件反射”的入门书。他的意思是学习者是操作者。学习者将有意识地、刻意地做出一种能让自己获益的行为。斯金纳盒子里的鸽子尝试了不同的事情。当它找到托盘时，它得到了食物。实际上，鸽子是在自我教学。
It was a primer on what BF Skinner called Operant Conditioning. What he meant by that was that the learner is the operator. The learner is going to deliberately consciously do a behavior that will pay off for the learner. The pigeon in Skinner's box tried different things. When it found the tray, it got the food. The pigeon, in effect, was teaching itself.
它在探索盒子，弄清楚什么有效。Karen对这个想法很着迷，但有一点她不喜欢，那就是手册中内置的所有惩罚措施。比如，如果海豚表现不正确，他们会饿它们24小时。这对这些动物来说是个非常糟糕的主意。它们从食物中获取所有水分，很快就会因脱水而死亡。所以你知道，里面有很多东西我直接跳过了。Karen废除了惩罚，但强调了手册中的另一个想法。
It was exploring the box and figuring out what worked. Karen was enamored with this idea, but one thing she didn't care for was all the punishment built into her manual. Like, if the dolphins didn't behave correctly, they would starve them for 24 hours. That's a very bad idea for these animals. They get all their water from their food and they can die of dehydration pretty quickly. So do you know there were a lot of things in there that I just jumped right away. Karen scrapped the punishments but emphasized another idea from the manual.
她建议将食物奖励与声音信号结合起来。她选择了一个哨子。在某种程度上，这是在巴甫洛夫的基础上建立的。正如巴甫洛夫发现狗会对节拍器的声音流口水一样，手册建议声音可以用来精确标记动物何时做了训练师想要的行为。哨子是一个信号，表示在这一刻你做得完全正确。所以你会得到奖励，但对于学习者来说，识别出你到底做了什么，当你做对时，那个声音信号，那个声学信息，无论它以什么形式出现，那实际上是一种快感。
The suggestion that she combined food rewards with an audible signal. She chose a whistle. In some ways, this was building on Pavlov. Just as Pavlov had found that dogs would salivate at the sound of a metronome, the manual suggested that sounds could be used to precisely mark when an animal did something the trainer wanted. The whistle is the signal that at this very instant you're doing absolutely the right thing. So you're going to get a prize, but the identification for the learner of exactly what you do, what you're when you have got it right, that acoustic sound, that acoustic message, whatever form
Barry Schwartz说，这个信号就像一个占位符。动物听到响片会感到高兴，因为响片与食物相关联。现在你可以使用响片，它比食物干扰小得多，来产生这一长串的行为，从而赢得观众的掌声。Karen开始工作了。她买了一个挂秤，这样她就可以记录每只动物需要多少食物来填饱肚子。她制定了训练计划，并设想了一个海豚可以表演的节目。你知道，要制作任何形式的节目，你需要开头、中间、高潮和圆满的结局。于是Karen写了一个关于古老夏威夷的节目。里面有草裙舞女孩、独木舟，当然还有很多海豚。然后我们开始训练。她从基础开始。简单的行为，比如把鼻子伸出水面。
that comes in, that is actually a thrill. Barry Schwat says the signal is like a placeholder. The animal feels good to hear the clicker because the clicker is associated with food. And now you can use the clicker, which is much less disruptive than the food, to produce this long chain of behavior that produces usanas from the people who are watching. Karen got to work. She bought a hanging scale so she could keep track of how much food each animal needed to
然后在此基础上增加技能。把鼻子伸得更高、更高、更高，直到你用尾巴站立。然后Karen变得更花哨了。她让人制造了一台能在水下发出哨声的机器，这样她就可以指挥海豚成群结队地表演技巧。Karen承认她消耗了很多鱼。六个月后，公园向公众开放。如果到处都是苍蝇，
fill up. She made a training schedule and she envisioned a show that dolphins could perform. You know, to make a show of any kind, you need a beginning in a middle and a high point and a happy ending. And so Karen wrote a show about old Hawaii. It had girls and grass curds and canoes and of course lots of dolphins. And then we began training. She started with basic stuff. Simple behaviors such as stick your nose out of the water.
这里有凉爽、清澈的蓝水。这是一个30万加仑的水箱，位于欧胡岛上，名为海洋生物公园的太平洋海洋乐园。Karen的海豚准备好了。在命令下，它们会旋转、翻转和拍打尾巴。它们看起来非常美妙。现在，这是它们的慢动作表演。突然，一位可爱的夏威夷美女出现，公园里的海豚用草裙舞来庆祝。
And then built on those skills. Stick your nose higher, higher, higher until you're standing on your tail. And then Karen got even fancier. She had a machine build that made whistle sounds underwater, so she could cue the dolphins to do tricks as a group. Karen admits she went through a lot of fish. Six months later, the park opened to the public. If there are flies everywhere,
Karen的技术迅速在海洋哺乳动物训练界传播开来，然后传播到各种其他动物训练中，从狗开始。如果你手里拿着零食，把它举在狗的头顶上方，很可能当你举起零食时，狗的屁股就会坐下。你点击的时刻就是你看到后腿肌肉移动到坐姿的时候。再到马。所以我要伸手到这里，在她的臀部上方轻轻拍一下。当她迈出那条腿时，我会给她标记信号，然后我会给她奖励。
so there is cool, clear, blue water. Here it's a 300,000 gallon tank, a Pacific marine land called Sea Life Park on the island of Oahu. Karen's dolphins were ready. On command, they would spin, flip and slap their tails. They are marvelous to watch. Now, here they are in slow motion. Suddenly, a lovely Hawaiian beauty appears and the parkuses celebrate with a hula.
再到像猫甚至鸡这样难以训练的动物。在这个视频中，我将展示我的鸡背带，并做一点响片训练。鸡、狗、猫、马、鲸鱼、雪貂。它们都已成功使用响片进行训练。有时，这些动物，比如Karen的海豚和后来她一起工作的狗，可以掌握精确度和复杂性令人叹为观止的技能。我们已经看到了伊万·巴甫洛夫的思想，经过B.F.斯金纳的修改和Karen Pryor的改编，可以成功地用于训练动物。
Carrons techniques quickly spread throughout the marine mammal training community and then to all kinds of other animal training from dogs. If you have a treat and you hold it over your dog's head, most likely as you lift the treat up, the dog's butt will go down. And the moment you're going to click is when you see the muscles of the back legs moving into the sit. To horses. So I'm going to reach up here, give her a little tap on top of her rump. And when she steps that leg in, I'm going to give her the marker signal, and then I'll give her a reward.
有一个显而易见的后续问题。如果响片在训练猫和狗方面如此有效，它们能在帮助人类学习方面发挥作用吗？在20世纪60年代，Karen Pryor发现正强化与哨子结合是训练海豚的强大工具。她的工作奠定了我们今天所知的响片训练的基础。它被用于各种动物，但在狗身上最受欢迎。嗨，我是Marty，这是我的狗Meg，今天我们将向你们展示我们能做的一些事情。
To hear to four untrainable animals like cats, even chickens. In this video I'll be showing you my chicken inner harness and doing a little quicker training. Chickens, dogs, cats, horses, whales, ferrets. They've all been successfully trained using a clicker. Sometimes these animals, like Karen's dolphins and later the dog she walked with, can master skills that are breathtaking in their precision and complexity. We've seen how the ideas of Ivan Pavlov, modified by BF Skinner and adapted by Karen Pryor, could be successfully used to train animals.
Martin Levy是响片的忠实粉丝。他用它们来训练他的狗表演复杂的技巧。Martin有一个网站，上面有视频展示了他训练的狗的技能，翻筋斗、蛇形跑和飞跃。Martin几年前迷上了这项运动。他很快意识到他不仅要训练他的狗，还要训练自己。刚开始时，他在一个动作上挣扎。他就是掌握不了。
There's an obvious next question. If clickers work so well in training cats and dogs, can they play a role in helping humans learn? In the 1960s, Karen Pryor discovered that positive reinforcement, combined with a whistle, was a powerful tool for training dolphins. Her work established the foundation of what we know today as clicker training. It's used with animals of all kinds, but remains most popular with dogs. Hi, I'm Marty and this is my dog Meg, and we're going to show you some of the things we can do today.
我当时正试图学习投掷正手腕部翻转。当我投掷飞盘时，飞盘会翻转。所以我寻求帮助。教练们向我挥手，告诉我改变手的位置，在我投掷时对我大喊大叫，但飞盘还是失败了。它还是翻滚了。我知道的是，我手的位置至关重要。为了让这个动作成功，我的拇指必须低于小指。但Martin似乎就是无法把手放到正确的位置。所以我买了一面舞蹈镜，把它放在地下室，抓了一个渔网放在镜子前面，这样我就可以对着它投掷。立刻显而易见的是，我的拇指比小指高。好吧，现在我可以做的是走到镜子前，把拇指放在小指下方的位置。在做这个动作的同时，我可以感觉到我的前臂是什么感觉，我可以感觉到前臂的压力，我可以感觉到手腕的感觉，现在我可以对着镜子投掷，并确保拇指在小指下方。这对Martin来说是一个巨大的学习时刻。镜子做了一件非常重要的事情。它为他提供了即时反馈。所以在这里我正在教授一项技能。我正在教我自己。通过镜像，我可以感觉到它的感觉，然后执行。
Martin Levy is a big fan of clickers. He uses them to train his dogs to perform complex tricks. Martin has a website with videos showing off the skills he started's dogs, summer sols and serpentines and flying leaps. Martin got hooked on the sport some years ago. He quickly realized he didn't just have to train his dog. He had to train himself. When he was starting out he struggled with one move. He just couldn't master it.
在某种重要的方式上，Martin就像B.F.斯金纳的鸽子。他站在镜子前，尝试不同的手部位置。通过反复试验，他正在自学如何投掷飞盘，就像鸽子自学盒子是如何工作的一样。Martin想把他学到的东西运用到他作为飞盘教练的工作中。他只需要比舞蹈镜和渔网更便携的东西。Martin熟悉Karen Pryor与海豚和狗的工作，他开始怀疑响片是否能达到和镜子一样的效果。提供即时反馈。如果我能那样指导会怎样？我可以告诉某人，我希望你旋转你的手直到……然后我会说，是的，我可以标记那个。现在有了那个反馈，你有了那种即时的反馈，没有所有的噪音，没有所有的谈话，一个简单的“好”。所以，我真正着迷的一件事是镜子的作用。
I was trying to learn to throw a forehand wrist flip. When I would throw the disc, the disc would turn over. So I saw it help. I had coaches waving at me, telling me to change the position of my hand, screaming at me while I was throwing, and the disc still failed. It still rolled over. The thing that I knew was that the position of my hand was critical. My thumb had to be lower than my pinky in order for this to work. But Martin just couldn't seem to get his hand into the right position. So I got a dance mirror, and I put in my basement and I grabbed a fisherman's net and I put it in front of the mirror so I could throw at it. And what became immediately evident was my thumb was higher than my pinky. Okay, now what I could do was to walk over to the mirror and I could put my
因为在某种程度上，是的，你可以看到你在做什么。但还有另一件非常重要的事情，那就是镜子不会告诉你“你这个笨蛋，我告诉过你多少次把拇指放在小指下面”。它不是主观的，它是一个非常客观的发现，这就是标记的意义所在。它是“哦，你终于做到了”，不，不是那样，它只是“是的，就是这样，你做到了”。不，不是那样。它只是，“是的。就是这样。你做到了。”他决定在他领导的自由式飞盘入门课上尝试一下，在那里他教人们正确投掷飞盘。
thumb in a position where it was below my pinky. While in doing that I could feel what my forearm felt like I could feel the stress in my forearm I could feel how my wrist felt and now I could throw at the mirror and make sure that my thumb was under the pinky. It was a huge learning moment for Martin. The mirror was doing something very important. It was providing him with instantaneous feedback. So here I'm teaching a skill. I'm teaching it to myself. And by mirroring that, I could feel what it felt like
这门课最大的崩溃点之一是，我有非常有活力的狗，它们变得非常沮丧，因为人们一直把它们扔到地上。所以Martin拿出了他的响片。听起来是这样的。现在，有些人认为把人像狗一样对待是贬低，但这群听众很乐意接受。他们都是老狗训练师，他们都熟悉响片。所以拿出响片说，我要用这个你在其他场合一直使用的东西来精确标记这一点。我要为你使用它。他基本上就像他用来训练自己的镜子一样。我会非常仔细地观察，一旦他们击中目标，砰，点击。他们的手处于正确的位置，点击。所以现在我可以用它来训练他们。
and now execute. In one important way, Martin was like B.F. Skinner's pigeon. He was standing in front of the mirror, trying different hand positions. Through trial and error, he was teaching himself how to throw the frisbee, just like the pigeon, taught itself how the box worked. Martin wanted to take what he'd learned into his work as a frisbee coach. He just needed something a little more portable than a dance mirror and a fisherman's net. Martin was familiar with Karen Price's work with dolphins and dogs and he began to wonder whether a
而且它奏效了。好吧，事实证明这是一种非常棒的方法。Martin的飞盘学生与B.F.斯金纳的鸽子有一个重要的不同之处。鸟儿探索盒子是因为它们想得到食物的奖励。对于Martin的学生来说，情况非常不同。他们中没有人需要被激励去学习投掷飞盘。他们已经有了那种动力。响片不是被用来操纵他们去做他们不想做的事情。它是在帮助他们学习他们已经想学的技能。
clicker might accomplish the same thing as a mirror. Provide instantaneous feedback. What if I could coach like that? I could tell someone I want you to rotate your hand until and I'm gonna go. yes, I can mark that. And now that feedback, you have that immediate feedback without all the noise, without all the talking, a simple good. So one of the things I'm really fascinated by is sort of what the mirror does.
Martin发现他用响片提供的反馈似乎比他能给出的任何口头表扬或批评都更有效。他意识到，当他保持沉默，只用点击声标记学生的正确手部位置时，他们似乎有更多的学习空间。他以前的做法，说“干得好”或“不，那是错的”。那种语言不仅没有帮助，实际上可能还阻碍了学习。这是因为表扬和批评往往会让学生关注表扬和批评本身。这让他们专注于老师，就像我以前对我父亲那样。
Because in some ways, yes, you can see what you're doing. But there's also something else that's very important, which is the mirror is not telling you you're dumb idiot how many times have I told you put the thumb below the pinky it's not subjective it's a very objective finding and that's what marking is it is oh you finally did it no it's not that it's just yes that's it you've got it. No, it's not that. It's just, yes. That's it. You've got it. He decided to try it out in the introduction to freestyle frisbee class that he leads where he teaches people to throw frisbee's correctly.
没有这些情绪上的交叉干扰，学生们可以专注于他们正在学习的任务。当他们成功时，当飞盘飞得又直又准时，他们的快乐不是来自老师的反馈，而是来自掌握技能的简单快乐。Martin意识到，如果它对飞盘爱好者有效，它可能在其他地方也有效。所以他决定在日常工作中测试一下。在一个下雨的周二早上，我前往布朗克斯的蒙特菲奥里医学中心，这是纽约的一家大型教学医院。在骨科楼层，我发现候诊室里挤满了人。
And one of the biggest breakdowns of that class is that I have very energized dogs who are getting very frustrated because people keep throwing them into the ground. So Martin pulled out his clicker. It sounds like this. Now, some I think it's demeaning to treat people like dogs, but this was a receptive audience. They're old dog trainers, and they were all familiar with clickers. So to pull it clicker out and to say, I'm going to mark this precisely with this thing that you've used all the time in another setting. I'm going to use it for you. He was basically acting like the mirror that he'd used to train himself. I would watch very closely and as soon as they hit the spot, boom, click. Their hand was in the correct position, click. So now I could use that to train them.
场景感觉很熟悉。忙碌的接待员，一些打瞌睡的病人，还有一台播放家居改造节目的电视。Martin Levy走过来迎接我和我的制片人。嗨，你们好吗？来吧，我带你们进去。在日常工作中，Martin是蒙特菲奥里的一名骨科医生。他修复受伤的运动员已经超过40年了。还有前交叉韧带重建，
And it worked. Well, it turned out to be a wonderful way to do it. There was an important way Martin's Frisbee students were different than B.F. Skinner's pigeons. The birds were exploring the box because they wanted to get the reward of food. With Martin's students, it was very different. None of them needed to be motivated to learn to throw the Frisbee. They had that motivation already. The clicker wasn't being used to manipulate them into doing something they didn't want to do. It was helping them. Learn a skill they already wanted to learn.
半月板手术，无论是修复还是切除。他带我穿过走廊来到一个小工作室，就像圣诞老人可能会有的那种。我们正走进技能实验室。里面挤满了橙色的家得宝桶、锯子、钻头、木头、绳子。这里我们有两种类型的钻头，一种较小，另一种在另一边。Martin告诉我，骨科手术建立在非常基础的木工活之上。他的工作之一是教新来的住院医生这些技能。
Martin discovered that the feedback he provided with the clicker seemed more effective than any verbal praise or criticism he could give. He realized that when he stayed silent and only marked a student's correct hand position with a click, they seemed to be more room for learning. The old way he'd done it, saying, great job or no, that's wrong. That language not only didn't help, it may actually have gotten in the way. That's because praise and criticism tend to make students pay attention to praise and criticism. It makes them focus on their teacher, just like I had done with my dad.
所以我们需要教他们打各种各样的结。他们需要能够钻孔。他们需要能够拧螺丝。他们需要能够使用被称为铰刀的设备，在那里他们切割孔或挖掘大的插槽。对于Martin来说，标准很高。他需要教授技能。他还要求他的学生在一个压力巨大且干扰众多的环境中执行这些技能。
Without these emotional cross-currents, the students could concentrate on the tasks they were learning. When they succeeded, when the frisbee flew straight and true, their pleasure came not from their teacher's feedback, but from the simple joy of mastering the skill. Martin realized that if it worked with frisbee enthusiasts, it might also work elsewhere. So he decided to test it out at his day job. On a rainy Tuesday morning, I head to the Bronx Montefur Medical Center, a large teaching hospital in New York. Up on the orthopedics floor, I find a waiting room dense with people.
当他们进入手术室时，外科医生需要将那种技术转化为肌肉记忆。Martin使用了棒球比赛的类比。棒球中的自杀式挤压战术是我最喜欢的战术之一。它始于三垒有人试图得分。此时击球手试图触击球，将其投入比赛，而三垒的跑垒员正在跑向本垒。当你看着球场时，所有这些活动都在进行。三垒手在冲撞，一垒手在冲撞。投手正试图把球投向击球手，
The scene feels familiar. I harried receptionist, some snoozing patients, and a TV playing a home remodeling show. Martin Levy walks up to greet me and my producer. Hi, this are you? Come on, let's get you company. In his day job, Martin is an orthopedic surgeon here at Montefur. He's been fixing broken athletes for more than 40 years. And to your cruciate ligament reconstructions,
所以我们不能有效地触击球。最重要的是，有一个跑垒员正向触击者跑来。所以当我们想要有效地执行触击时，在一个高度紧张的环境中，在所有这些情况下，我们需要练习触击。Martin希望他的学生知道如何使用他们的工具，就像伟大的棒球运动员知道如何触击一样。所以他设计了一个实验室，学生们可以在那里练习到完美。
meniscal surgery, whether it be repair or resection. He leads me down the hallway to a little workshop, like something Santa might have. We're walking into the skills laboratory. It's crammed with orange, home depot buckets, saws, drills, wood, rope. Here we have two types of drills, one a smaller one, and one in the other. Martin tells me orthopedic surgery is built on pretty basic carpentry. One of his jobs is to teach incoming residents these skills.
技能实验室的目标是拿取工具并教授每种单独的工具，直到它可以被熟练使用。棒球棒。任何球都可以被触击到场内，钻头。在任何位置，使用任何钻头，在任何材料上，用任何形状，都可以钻出一个孔。Martin在设计他的实验室时遇到了一些挑战。成本就是其中之一。在尸体和塑料骨骼等医疗级材料上练习根本没有意义。它们很贵。
So we need to teach them to tie a variety of knots. They need to be able to drill a hole. They need to be able to put a screw in. They need to be able to use devices known as reemers where they cut holes or they gouge large sockets. For Martin, the bar is high. He needs to teach skills. He also needs his students to perform those skills in an environment where there's huge pressure and many distractions.
而且尸体供应有限。相反，他想出了便宜的替代品，如PVC管、麻绳和2x4木板。Martin甚至想出了一些有趣的人体替代品。我最喜欢的模型之一是茄子上的石膏。他们给茄子打上像骨折手臂上那样的石膏，然后要求住院医生在不切到茄子的情况下锯掉石膏。茄子非常类似于脆弱的皮肤。
When they go into an operating room, surgeons need to have that technique down to muscle memory. Martin uses the analogy of a baseball play. The suicide squeeze in baseball is one of my favorite plays. It starts with a man at third base trying to score. The batter at this point attempts to bump the ball, put it in play while the runner at third base is running home. When you look at the field, there's all of these activities going on. The third base minute is crashing, the first basement is crashing. The picture is trying to throw the ball at the batter,
所以上面的石膏让住院医生有机会在不伤害任何人的情况下真正测试他们的技能，但如果茄子漏水了，那么你需要继续练习。所以想象一下这个实验室，它很安静，充满了廉价的材料，而且没有压力。学生们可以练习尽可能长的时间。当然，Martin还有另一个廉价且简单的教学工具。响片。所以，早上好，Zach。所以，我们今天要做的就是……
so we can't bump the ball effectively. And on top of it, there's a runner that's running right at the bunter. So when we're wanted for us to execute a bunter effectively, in a highly charged environment, with all of this going on, we need to practice bunting. Martin wants his students to know how to use their tools in the same way a great baseball player knows how to bun. So he designed a lab where students could practice to perfection.
在这一天，Martin和他的学生之一Zachary Sharfman在一起。我是PGY1，意思是研究生一年级。那是你从医学院毕业后的第一年。Zach在这里练习一个特定的结。Martin说这在骨科手术中至关重要。滑动结在肩部手术中很有用，因为它允许我们将软组织固定到骨头上。如果你能想象这里末端有一个锚，然后我们能做的是能够把软组织推到骨头上并系住它。首先Martin向Zach展示如何打这个结。好吧，首先这是它
The goal of the skill lab is to take tools and to teach each individual tool until it can be used fluently. The baseball bat. Any pitch can be bonded into the field, the drill. In any position, with any drill bit, on any material, with any shape, a drill hole can be made. Martin had some challenges in designing his lab. Cost was one. Practicing on medical grade materials like cadavers and plastic bones just didn't make sense. They're expensive.
看起来的样子。他在一段绳子上演示。好吧，这就是一个完成的结。所以让我们去构建它。每次Zach正确执行一个步骤，Martin都会用点击声确认。这个步骤的第一步是将三分之一的绳子直接放在三分之二的绳子上方。标签点在上方。我们要重复五次，每次你击中标签点，我都会用标记器标记它。如果你在做的时候说出来，三分之一在三分之二上方。三分之一在三分之二上方。如果你能再做一次，拜托。
And cadavers, they're limited supply. Instead, he came up with cheap substitutes like PVC pipe, twine, and 2x4. Martin even came up with some interesting replacements for the human body. One of my favorite models is the cast on an eggplant. They put an actual cast like you'd have on a broken arm on an eggplant and then they ask residents to saw off the cast without cutting the eggplant. And eggplant is very similar to fragile skin.
在五次成功的点击后，他们开始下一步，然后是下一步，直到他们到达最后一步。三分之一在三分之二上方，穿过假捏。背面抓取，整理结。谢谢。在整个课程中，完全没有情绪化的语言。没有，“干得好”，或“做得好”，或“不，错了。你在做什么？”完全没有这些。
So the cast on there gives the resident the opportunity to really test their skill without hurting anybody but if the eggplant is leaking then you need to keep practicing. So picture the lab, it's quiet, full of inexpensive materials, and there's no pressure. Students can practice for as long as they need. And of course, Martin has another cheap and simple teaching tool. The clicker. So, good morning, Zach. So, what we're going to do today is...
唯一的反馈是响片的点击声。学生唯一的奖励是掌握了技能，而不是老师的认可。这就是我使用响片的原因。它没有包袱。它是无情绪的。Zach Sharfman和Martin一起练习过各种各样的结。他说当他完美掌握一个结时，
On this day, Martin's with one of his students, Zachary Sharfman. I'm a PGY1, which means post-grad year one. That's your first year after you've graduated from medical school. Zag is here to practice one particular knot. One that Martin says is crucial in orthopedic surgery. A slider knot is useful in shoulder surgery because it allows us to be able to fix soft tissue to bone. If you can imagine there's an anchor at the end of this and then what we'd be able to do is be able to push soft tissue down to the bone and tie it. First Martin shows Zach how to tie the knot. Alright first this is what it
他的手指自然就知道该怎么做。我认为一个很好的表达方式是，如果你准备好弹响手指，我挑战你这样做并准备好，很难不弹响。我认为我们在这里真正开发的是一种方式，即绳子在你的手中，它已加载，你准备好弹响，它自然而然地就发生了。Martin Levy的响片训练技术使他成为医学界的异类，但响片训练正在成为各个领域的固定装置。它被用来帮助人们
looks like. He demonstrates on a length of row. Okay and that's a completed knot. So let's go build that. Each time Zack performs a step correctly, Martin acknowledges it with a click. The first step of this is to place one-third of the rope directly over two-thirds of the rope. The tag point is over. We're going to do it five times and each time that you hit the tag point, I'm going to mark it with the marker. And if you would say it as you're doing it one- over two thirds. One third over two thirds. And if you do it again please.
成为更好的舞者、渔民和高尔夫球手。所以你到达上杆的顶部，点击，然后一旦你点击，你就在你的挥杆序列中继续。你想在击球时的冲击点再次点击。Martin使用各种教学工具。响片只是其中之一。但它传达的教训至关重要。我们从响片开始，教人们如何不使用语言并进行非常精确的标记。我们在很短的时间内将他们过渡到其他方法。例如，当锯子打开时，你听不到响片。
After five successful clicks they begin the next step and then the next until they reach the final step. Third over two thirds over and through the faking pinch. The backside grab, dress the knot. Thank you. Throughout the lesson, there's a complete absence of emotional language. No, great job, or well done, or no, wrong. What are you doing? There's none of that.
所以我们使用手电筒。我们过渡到使用一个非常温和的“好”。它只是一个标记。你已经精确击中了目标。我要告诉你的一个有趣的故事是，你有两个学习者。第一个学习者非常出色，他们在很短的时间内就完成了你所教的所有内容，你说，“好，干得好”。下一个学习者有困难，你和他们一起工作了三、四
The only feedback is the sound of the clicker. The only reward for the student is the mastery of the skill, not the approval of the teacher. This is why I use the clicker. It is baggage free. It is emotional free. Zach Sharfman has worked with Martin on a variety of knots. He says when he's got one down perfectly,
或十分钟，你坐在那里，他们终于做到了。你说，“干得好，太棒了”。第一个学习者坐在那里想，“什么？我不明白。他挣扎了。他得到了所有的赞美，而我，我只得到了一个‘好’。”好吧，如果每个人都得到“好”，那么我们就没有它带来的包袱了。你一定从一些人、一些住院医生、一些住院医生的父母那里听到过反应，说，“这太荒谬了。你怎么能像教狗一样教我们的孩子？”我还没有遇到过任何人感到惊讶。每个人都和我们一起工作。我想我听到的唯一评论是“我女朋友就是这样训练她的狗的”，我说“是的，我敢打赌它非常有效”，他说“是的，它很棒”。我们在开始之前告诉他们。这是操作性
his fingers just know what to do. I think a nice way to put it is, if you put your fingers ready to snap and I challenge you to do that and get them ready, it's hard to not snap. And what I think we're really developing here is a way to say the ropes in your hand, it's loaded, you're ready to snap, it just comes naturally. Martin Levy's Clicker Training Techn techniques make him an outlier in medicine, but click-or-training is becoming a fixture in a variety of fields. It's being used to help people
学习，这是背后的概念，坚持住，它会奏效的。响片训练的核心是一个激进的想法。它表明教学可以在没有批评的情况下有效，也可以在没有表扬的情况下有效。现在，你可能认为这使得老师变得不重要。你完全错了。老师绝不是旁观者。这是因为正是老师设计了学生学习的世界。换句话说，教鸽子的挑战实际上并不在于教鸽子。
become better dancers, fishermen, and golfers. So you get to the top of your backswing, hit the click, and then once you hit hit the click, you're doing an obviously go with your dance wing sequence. You want to hit that click again at the impact sign when you hit the ball. Martin uses a variety of teaching tools. The clicker is just one of them. But the lesson it imparts is crucial. We start with a clicker to teach people how to be language free and to mark very precisely. We transition them over a very short period of time to other methodologies. For instance, you can't hear a clicker when a saw is on.
挑战在于建立一个鸽子可以学习的盒子。如何设计学习，使其变得自然、普遍，甚至可预测？请继续关注我们。每个人都能想到学习中事情崩溃的时刻。原因之一是专家往往是糟糕的老师。一旦你掌握了一项技能，就很难记住不知道这项技能是什么感觉。一旦你知道如何骑自行车，你可能会对新手说，“推一下，开始踩踏板”。回到过去，记住当某件事看起来令人困惑或不可能时是什么感觉，需要巨大的同理心。
So we use flashlights. We transition to using a very benign good. It is just a mark. You have hit the target precisely. One of the interesting stories to tell you is that you have two learners. The first learner is exceptional and they get through exactly what you're teaching in a very short period of time and you say, good, great job. The next learner has difficulty and you work with them for three or four
这有时被称为“专业知识的诅咒”。专家忘记了学习某件事有多么困难，因为他们已经掌握了它。我正在为小孩子教篮球。又是骨科住院医生Zach Scharffman。这一次，他扮演的是老师而不是学生。我走到罚球线。我运球，我用我习惯的方式旋转球。我把脚放在正确的位置，我把臀部和肩膀对准篮筐，我收起
or ten minutes and you're sitting there and they finally get in. You go, wait a go, that's terrific. And the first learner is sitting there going, what? I don't get this. He struggled. He gets all the accolades and I, I got a good. Well, if everybody gets good, then we don't have the baggage that that brings. What was, you must have heard reactions from some people, some residents, some parents of residents sort of saying, this is ridiculous. How can you teach our kids the way you're teaching dogs? I haven't had anybody taken back. Everybody has worked with us. I think the the only comment I've ever heard is my girlfriend trains her dog this way and I said yes and I bet you it was really effective and he said yeah it was great. We tell them before we start. This is operant
或者十分钟，你坐在那里，他们终于进去了。你会说，等等，太棒了。而第一个学习者坐在那里想，什么？我不明白。他很挣扎。他得到了所有的赞誉，而我，我只得到了一个好。好吧，如果每个人都得到好，那么我们就不会有随之而来的包袱。你一定听到过一些人、一些住院医生、一些住院医生的父母的反应，他们说，这太荒谬了。你怎么能用教狗的方式教我们的孩子呢？我没有遇到过任何退缩的人。每个人都和我们合作过。我想我听到的唯一的评论是，我女朋友就是这样训练她的狗的，我说是的，我敢打赌它非常有效，他说是的，这太棒了。我们在开始之前就告诉他们。这是操作性
learning, here's the concepts behind it and hang in there, It's going to work. There's a radical idea at the heart of click or training. It suggests that teaching can be effective without the use of criticism, but also without the use of praise. Now, you might think that this makes teachers unimportant. You'd be completely wrong. The teacher is anything but a bystander. That's because it's the teacher who designs the world in which the student learns. To put this another way, the challenge in teaching pigeons doesn't actually lie in teaching pigeons.
学习，这就是它背后的概念，坚持住，它会奏效的。响片训练的核心是一个激进的想法。它表明，教学可以在没有批评的情况下有效，但也可以在没有赞美的情况下有效。现在，你可能认为这使得老师变得不重要。你完全错了。老师绝不是旁观者。这是因为正是老师设计了学生学习的世界。换句话说，教鸽子的挑战实际上并不在于教鸽子。
The challenge lies in building a box in which the pigeons can learn. How to design learning so it becomes natural, commonplace, even predictable? Stay with us. Everyone can think of learning moments when things broke down. One reason for this is that experts often make poor teachers. Once you've mastered a skill, it becomes difficult to remember what it felt like to not know the skill. Once you know how to write a bike, you might say to a newbie, just push off, start pedaling. It takes an enormous act of effort, of empathy, to go back and remember how it felt when something seemed confusing or impossible.
挑战在于建造一个鸽子可以学习的盒子。如何设计学习，使其变得自然、普遍，甚至可预测？请继续关注我们。每个人都能想到学习过程中出现故障的时刻。原因之一是专家往往不是好老师。一旦你掌握了一项技能，就很难记住不知道这项技能时的感觉。一旦你知道如何骑自行车，你可能会对新手说，只要推开，开始踩踏板就行了。这需要巨大的努力和同理心，才能回过头来记住当某件事看起来令人困惑或不可能时是什么感觉。
This is sometimes called the curse of expertise. Experts forget how difficult it can be to learn something because they've already mastered it. I was coaching basketball for little kids. Again, orthopedic resident Zach Scharffman. This time, he's playing the role of teacher rather than student. And I stepped up to a free throw line. I dribbled the ball, I spun it the way that I'm used to spinning it. I put my feet in the right position, I squared my hips and shoulders to the basket, I tucked
这有时被称为专家的诅咒。专家忘记了学习某件事有多么困难，因为他们已经掌握了它。我正在为小孩子做篮球教练。同样是骨科住院医生扎克·沙夫曼。这一次，他扮演的是老师而不是学生。我走到罚球线前。我运球，按照我习惯的方式旋转球。我把脚放在正确的位置，我把臀部和肩膀对准篮筐，我收起
my elbow in, I shot the ball, my hand arced and finished in the right position, I handed it to the kid and I said, go ahead do the same thing. Zach, as you can probably tell, is a very good basketball player. So good that he forgets how many little skills he's internalized in order to make the shot. The kid he was teaching didn't get it. And his feet are lined up wrong. And his shoulders are lined up wrong. And his elbows out to the side.
我把手肘内收，投出球，手腕划出一道弧线，并在正确的位置完成动作，我把它递给那个孩子，对他说，来吧，你也照做。扎克，正如你可能看出来的，是一位非常优秀的篮球运动员。他太优秀了，以至于忘记了自己为了投中这一球，已经内化了多少细小的技巧。他教的那个孩子没学会。孩子的脚站位不对，肩膀方向也不对，手肘还向外张开。
And the ball's sitting not square on his shooting hand, but it's sitting in between his two hands. I look at him and I go, what are you doing? It's not at all what I did. And it was completely unreasonable as a teacher for me to expect him to be able to shoot the ball that way. And I think what mattered was then slowing down
球没有稳稳地放在投篮手上，而是夹在两手之间。我看着他，心想，你在干什么？这跟我刚才做的完全不一样。作为老师，我期望他能那样投篮，这完全是不合理的。我认为重要的是要慢下来，
and going step by step and saying, okay, this is where your feet are. Now every time you get to this line, your feet start here. Don't think about catching the ball, don't grab the ball, don't worry about shooting. Start with your feet here. In other words, to be effective, Zach had to tease apart a complex procedure. He had to break his technique down into teachable parts. This is what Martin Levy calls task analysis, and it lies at the very heart of what you have to do to make clicker training work. It requires the teacher to possess not just expertise but the patience to deconstruct what they know into bite-sized pieces, to break down skills into their components and sub-components, and to keep doing this until every single student can master them. Arton says one of the great masters of task analysis was the Royals and White Sox baseball
一步一步地教，说，好吧，你的脚现在是这样放的。以后每次站到这条线上，你的脚都要从这里开始。别去想接球，别去抓球，别担心投篮。先从脚的位置开始。换句话说，为了达到效果，扎克必须把一个复杂的过程拆解开来。他必须把自己的技术分解成可教授的部分。这就是马丁·利维所说的任务分析，它正是让响片训练发挥作用的核心所在。这要求教师不仅要具备专业知识，还要有耐心，将自己所知的内容拆解成易于消化的碎片，将技能分解成各个组成部分和子部分，并不断重复，直到每一位学生都能掌握。阿顿说，任务分析的大师之一是皇家队和白袜队的棒球
coach, Charlie Lau. Even the great hitters and professional baseball need help. Welcome to the art of hitting 300 with Charlie Lau. What he did is he took a number of the greatest baseball players, greatest hitters of all time, and he looked at their swings and what he was able to find with their common points, there were commonalities in these swings. And when you took all the commonalities out, you could build this cookie cutter where you could take someone who wasn't a natural and you could say, follow these steps and
教练查理·劳。即使是职业棒球界的伟大击球手也需要帮助。欢迎来到查理·劳的“打击艺术300讲”。他所做的是选取了一些史上最伟大的棒球运动员和击球手，观察他们的挥棒动作，并找出其中的共同点，这些挥棒动作确实存在共性。当你提取出所有共性后，你就可以建立一个模版，即使是那些没有天赋的人，你也可以告诉他，按照这些步骤去做，
at least we'll get you close. This is what Martin Levy wants to do. Build a series of systematic steps to teach the skills he wants his students to learn. Martin needs to do it right. Medical residents, he says, seem to take criticism, especially hard. These are professionals who are highly motivated, who've done well in school, who want to be successful. So, when they're not performing up to expectation, it is unpleasant. They're not happy about it, and it's my job to get them past it. One way Martin gets students past it is to communicate that the responsibility for learning is really on him, the teacher. The student has to show up, be motivated. But if a student doesn't get something, that means Martin has done something wrong. The skill he's trying to teach has not been broken down sufficiently. The steps have not been rehearsed systematically. The fault lies not with the student, but with a teacher. So let's say we're tying a knot and there's six steps to tying the knot.
至少我们能让你接近目标。这就是马丁·利维想要做的。建立一系列系统的步骤来教授他希望学生掌握的技能。马丁需要把这件事做好。他说，医学住院医师似乎特别难以接受批评。他们都是积极性很高、在学校表现优异、渴望成功的专业人士。所以，当他们的表现未达预期时，这会让人很不愉快。他们对此感到不高兴，而我的工作就是帮助他们克服这种情绪。马丁帮助学生克服情绪的一种方法是传达这样一个理念：学习的责任其实在于他自己，也就是老师。学生需要到场，保持积极性。但如果学生没学会什么东西，那就意味着马丁做错了什么。他试图教授的技能没有被充分拆解。这些步骤没有经过系统的练习。错误不在学生，而在老师。所以，假设我们正在打一个结，打这个结有六个步骤。
And in the fourth step the knot is breaking down. We're just, it's not happening. Well, it's on the teacher at that point to say, okay, it may mean that we take a part that we always have done as one step and now it turns into two steps or three. But now the learner is successful. This is not the way learning unfolds in many parts of the world. Students are often blamed for their failure to learn. Sorry, sister.
而在第四步时，结打不成了。我们就是，它没成功。好吧，这时候老师就该说，好吧，这可能意味着我们得把原本作为一个步骤的部分拆成两个或三个步骤。但现在学习者成功了。这并不是世界上许多地方学习展开的方式。学生往往因为学不会而受到指责。抱歉，修女。
Now get yourself into the corner and put on the dumps his hat. Martin Levy has come to understand that the teacher's student relationship is complicated. One person has power, one does not. One person has expectations, one does not. One person cannot betrays. The other is hungry for any decision. This relationship can be destroyed in a single, unthinking moment. Martin remembers a time this happened, not with a resident, but with his dog Penny. We were working on a series of jumps, referred to as a serpentine. It's three jumps that are parallel to each other, and we kept knocking the middle bar down, and at the time I just picked up the bar, tapped the ground and went damn, and my dog ran off into a tunnel and hid.
现在去角落里戴上那顶笨蛋帽子。马丁·利维已经开始明白，师生关系是很复杂的。一个人拥有权力，另一个人没有。一个人有期望，另一个人没有。一个人不能背叛，另一个人渴望任何决定。这种关系可能在瞬间被一个不经意的举动摧毁。马丁记得有一次发生了这种情况，不是和住院医师，而是和他的狗佩妮。我们当时正在练习一系列跳跃，称为蛇形跑。那是三个平行的跳栏，我们一直把中间的横杆碰掉，当时我只是捡起横杆，拍了拍地，说了句“该死”，我的狗就跑进隧道躲起来了。
It took Martin an hour and lots of treats to get her to come back out. Now medical residents who see a teacher get frustrated don't run into a tunnel and hide. They don't usually reveal feelings of humiliation or shame, but they are listening and internalizing those reactions. The voices of teachers, and this is something Freud might have said, become part of the way students talk to themselves. I think the take-home message from that, for me, was how fragile learning moments can be, where everybody's trying hard, the dog was trying hard to be successful,
马丁花了一个小时和大量的零食才让它重新出来。现在，看到老师感到沮丧的住院医师不会跑进隧道躲起来。他们通常不会表现出屈辱或羞耻感，但他们正在倾听并内化这些反应。老师的声音，这可能是弗洛伊德会说的话，成为了学生自我对话的一部分。我认为从中得到的启示是，学习时刻是多么脆弱，每个人都在努力，狗在努力想要成功，
I was trying hard to be successful, but just a simple action of damn. And the dog interpreted that as her failure and was not able to perform after that for a couple of days. Martin says the clicker can help you take frustration out of the equation. And this is a very good method of freeing people up, opening them up, allowing them to accept new information without all of the debris that comes along with it. I'm quiet, you're quiet.
我也在努力想要成功，但仅仅是一个简单的“该死”的动作，狗就将其解读为它的失败，之后几天都无法完成动作。马丁说，响片可以帮你把挫败感从等式中剔除。这是一种非常好的方法，可以解放人们，让他们敞开心扉，在没有伴随而来的负面情绪干扰下接受新信息。我安静，你安静。
We're just learning a skill. But I think what I'm hearing you say is that there's all of this psychological relationship between teacher and student, which in some ways is crowding the actual engagement with the material itself. What is my teacher? Think of me, does my teacher like me,
我们只是在学习一项技能。但我认为我听到你说的是，师生之间存在着各种心理关系，在某种程度上，这挤占了对材料本身的实际接触。我的老师怎么看我，我的老师喜欢我吗，
does my teacher hate me, does my teacher approve of me, does my teacher disapprove of me, am I doing it right? Am I doing it better with my friend, am I faster than my friend, am I can I show the teacher, am I actually a really good student, can I show the teacher, am the best student that the teacher has ever had, I have all the stuff going on in my head. And what that's getting in the way off is pull the string. So one third of it is over the other two thirds. You've said it precisely. I'd like to bring you into my lecture and just say that because that is the entire story. How can we eliminate all the noise?
我的老师讨厌我吗，我的老师认可我吗，我的老师不认可我吗，我做得对吗？我做得比朋友好吗，我比朋友快吗，我能向老师展示吗，我真的是个好学生吗，我能向老师展示我是老师教过的最好的学生吗，我的脑子里充斥着这些东西。而这阻碍了——拉紧绳子。所以三分之一在另外三分之二上面。你说得太对了。我想把你带到我的讲座里，就说这些，因为这就是整个故事。我们如何消除所有的噪音？
In the skills lab, Martin breaks down many of the procedures himself. Tying knots, sawing, drilling. But one of the most important things he does is not with students but with his senior colleagues. Sometimes even the best surgeons can't explain how they do what they do, like building an acetabum, the socket for a hip joint. How do you do it? I'm no idea, I just do it. Greatest hitters in the world. How do you do it?
在技能实验室里，马丁亲自拆解了许多程序。打结、锯木、钻孔。但他所做的最重要的事情之一不是针对学生，而是针对他的资深同事。有时即使是最优秀的外科医生也无法解释他们是如何完成工作的，比如构建髋臼，即髋关节的窝。你是怎么做到的？我不知道，我就是这么做了。世界上最伟大的击球手。你是怎么做到的？
See the ball hit the ball. That doesn't help me a lot. It doesn't really me a lot. It doesn't really get me very far, especially if I'm not unnatural. So what we do is we ask that skilled surgeon to sit down and build his astound. Now I'm going to watch you. Do it again. Do it again. Okay, here's what I saw. And I'm going to start to write down. You positioned your feet here. You bent your knees. you held the drill like this, your elbow was in this position, your hands were in this position. And let's let me demonstrate what I saw.
看球，打球。这对我帮助不大。它真的没帮我什么。它真的没让我走多远，尤其是如果我没有天赋的话。所以我们做的是，请那位熟练的外科医生坐下来，构建他的髋臼。现在我要观察你。再做一次。再做一次。好吧，这是我看到的。我开始写下来。你的脚放在这里。你弯曲了膝盖。你这样握着钻头，你的手肘在这个位置，你的手在这个位置。让我演示一下我所看到的。
So now I demonstrate what I saw. And he says, yes, that's it. Or no, we need to correct this. My hand is actually like this. Okay. And then we can build it. And now we can turn it into a structured algorithm where I can give it back to someone and I can say, here are your targets. Put your feet like this. Put your knees like this. We're going to mark each one of those things. We're going to just do it until you're comfortable at each one of those steps. And now we've built someone who can reproduce what that person did. There's a profoundly democratic idea at the heart of this approach. It's understandable for teachers to gravitate to students who are natural,
现在我演示我所看到的。他说，是的，就是这样。或者不，我们需要纠正这一点。我的手其实是这样的。好的。然后我们可以构建它。现在我们可以把它变成一个结构化的算法，我可以把它传授给别人，我可以说，这是你的目标。把脚这样放。把膝盖这样放。我们要标记每一个步骤。我们要一直练习，直到你在每一个步骤都感到舒适。现在我们培养出了一个能够复制那个人动作的人。这种方法的核心是一个深刻的民主理念。老师倾向于那些有天赋的学生是可以理解的，
for whom learning is almost effortless. Clicker training is really for the rest of us. As Martin says, you don't have to be a natural to get really, really good at something. For us, we want surgeons to be very talented, but everyone isn't going to be a wizard. We just want you to be really, really good, and we can get you there. If we take our time and we build these skills, we very much believe we can get you there. One of the reasons Martin might be the perfect evangelist for clicker training is that he understands how easy it is
对他们来说，学习几乎是不费吹灰之力的。响片训练其实是为我们其他人准备的。正如马丁所说，你不必是个天才也能在某件事上做得非常好。对我们来说，我们希望外科医生非常有天赋，但并不是每个人都能成为巫师。我们只是希望你做得非常好，我们可以带你达到那个水平。如果我们花时间，建立这些技能，我们非常相信我们可以带你达到那个水平。马丁之所以能成为响片训练的完美传播者，原因之一是他明白在学习过程中
to get lost while learning something. I don't think anything whether it was an athletic endeavor or it was surgery ever came very easy. I was not one of those kids that did it on the first try. This sounds a lot like me. When it comes to manual skills, I'm all thumbs. So I challenged Martin to teach me the same knot he taught Zach, his orthopedic resident. And I have to tell you, I'm not good with my hands.
迷失方向是多么容易。我不认为任何事情，无论是体育运动还是外科手术，是轻而易举的。我不是那种第一次尝试就成功了的孩子。这听起来很像我。说到手工技能，我笨手笨脚的。所以我挑战马丁教我他教给他的骨科住院医师扎克的同一个结。我必须告诉你，我不擅长动手。
I have, I'm pretty sure I'm going to screw up. Someone tells me to do something, I have a voice in the back of my head that says, you're probably going to make a mistake. Can you take on the challenge of trying to teach me something? Yes, we can teach you. And so we begin. The instructions are the same that Martin used with Zach up to a point.
我有，我很确定我会搞砸。有人告诉我做什么，我脑子里就会有一个声音说，你可能会犯错。你能接受挑战，试着教我点什么吗？是的，我们可以教你。于是我们开始了。指导语和马丁教扎克时的一样，直到某一点。
One third over two thirds. The tag point is over. One third of a two thirds. One third of a two thirds. A couple of times, Martin stops to show me 1.30 with 2.30. 1.30 with 2.30. A couple of times Martin stops to show me how to do something. My hands are too far apart, I've put the rope under, not over. There's neither approval nor disapproval on Martin's face and in his voice. I stop paying attention to him.
三分之一压在三分之二上。标记点在上面。三分之一压在三分之二上。三分之一压在三分之二上。马丁停下来几次向我展示如何做某事。我的手离得太远了，我把绳子放在了下面，而不是上面。马丁的脸上和声音里既没有赞许也没有不赞许。我不再关注他。
It's just a rope, my hands, and the clicker. One third of a two thirds. One third of a two thirds. I feel a quietness in my head. It allows me to concentrate. One third of a two thirds. Last one. One third of a two thirds. Of course, from time to time, my anxiety about tying the knot properly
只有绳子、我的手和响片。三分之一压在三分之二上。三分之一压在三分之二上。我感到脑子里一片宁静。这让我能够集中注意力。三分之一压在三分之二上。最后一个。三分之一压在三分之二上。当然，时不时地，我对能否打好结的焦虑
resurfaces. Now this is going to be the hard step and I'm going to screw up here. No, not. One-third over two-thirds. Wrap over and through. Wrap to a fakey pinch. Flatten the knot. The tag point is flatten the knot. One-third of a-one-third of a-two-thirds wrap over and through. Wrap to a fakey pinch flatten the knot. Something happened just now. I noticed it as I was working on the knot. The instructions that Martin gave me differed from those he gave Zach. Here, take a listen to what he told Zach. One-third over two-thirds wrap over over and through, wrap to a fakie pinch, behind, over, and through to a backside grab.
又浮现出来。现在这将是困难的一步，我会在这里搞砸的。不，不是。三分之一压在三分之二上。绕过并穿过。绕到一个假捏点。压平结。标记点是压平结。三分之一压在三分之二上，绕过并穿过。绕到一个假捏点，压平结。刚才发生了什么。我在打结时注意到了。马丁给我的指导语和他给扎克的不一样。听听他告诉扎克的话。三分之一压在三分之二上，绕过并穿过，绕到一个假捏点，在后面，绕过并穿过，抓到背面。
Let me demonstrate. What Zach did not have to do, and I did, was this step. Flatten the knot. The tag point is flatten the knot. I asked Martin why he'd added the step for me. There was a lot of information coming in that you were telling me before we even started. I'm what you told me was, I'm really nervous about doing this. I don't want to look like an idiot.
让我演示一下。扎克不需要做，而我需要做的，就是这一步。压平结。标记点是压平结。我问马丁为什么给我加了这一步。你在我们开始之前就告诉了我很多信息。你告诉我的内容是，我真的很紧张，不想看起来像个白痴。
I'm not really sure I can do this. Okay, that's data for me. And I've got to make it comfortable. We've got to slow it down. We've got to slow it down. We've got to make sure that you're seeing each step. If a step isn't working, I'm not going to necessarily let you work through it as long as someone else. I'm going to take over and give you information right away so you don't get frustrated and start to fall into that rabbit hole that you had where, uh-oh, I'm failing again. No, you're not. You're
我不确定我能不能做到。好吧，那是给我的数据。我必须让它变得舒适。我们必须慢下来。我们必须慢下来。我们必须确保你看到了每一步。如果某一步行不通，我不一定会让你像别人那样自己摸索。我会接手并立即给你信息，这样你就不会感到沮丧，也不会开始陷入你之前那种“噢，我又失败了”的深渊。不，你没有。你
right here. It's working. It's everything's good." And he was right. It was good. I finished the knot. It was empowering. Maybe that's the real key to this kind of training. It helps clear out some of the clutter in our minds. The negative chatter that psychologists Barry Schwartz says people experience all the time. We self-sabotage because of the way in which we talk to ourselves as we're going through our day. You know, I'm not any good at this. I'll never be successful.
就在这里。它起作用了。一切都很好。”他是对的。确实很好。我打好了结。这让人充满力量。也许这就是这种训练的真正关键所在。它有助于清除我们脑中的杂乱。心理学家巴里·施瓦茨所说的人们一直经历的负面唠叨。我们因为在一天中对自己说话的方式而自我破坏。你知道，我不擅长这个。我永远不会成功。
I should sit quietly. I shouldn't volunteer to take on new challenges because I'm not any good. And eventually they're going to discover that I'm already getting more responsibility than I deserve. You keep talking to yourself in that way. It's very self-defeating. To be sure, there are limits to this kind of teaching and learning. Barry Schwartz points out that there are times when great things come from the emotional interactions between teachers and students. What good teachers do, aside from communicating information, is they do establish relations with students
我应该安静地坐着。我不应该主动承担新的挑战，因为我不擅长。最终他们会发现我得到的责任已经超过了我应得的。你一直那样对自己说话。这是非常自我挫败的。当然，这种教学和学习方式是有局限性的。巴里·施瓦茨指出，有时伟大的事情来自于师生之间的情感互动。优秀的老师除了传达信息外，还会与学生建立关系，
that inspire the students to go beyond the specific lesson that's being taught that day or in that class. I became a psychologist because I was inspired by the teachers I had, especially the teacher who taught me my first psychology course when I was an 18-year-old who had no idea what psychology was. My entire life course was largely influenced by the inspiration provided by that teacher. It's true that a clicker cannot inspire or play the role of a mentor. It's a good
激励学生超越当天或那门课所教授的具体内容。我成为心理学家是因为我受到了老师的启发，尤其是那位在我18岁、对心理学一无所知时教我第一门心理学课程的老师。我的一生在很大程度上受到了那位老师所提供的灵感的启发。诚然，响片无法激励学生或扮演导师的角色。它是一个很好的
tool for a certain kind of learning, but that doesn't mean it's the right tool for all kinds of learning. And yet the clicker, when it is the right tool, can fix one of the most detrimental parts of the teacher's student relationship. When students start to care more about getting praise and avoiding criticism, then learning. If the student wants the feedback more than the actual skill, well then you start to see these things go wrong. You know, you have students who do whatever they think it takes to get the approval of their teacher, whether or not it contributes to their mastery of the material.
工具，适用于某种学习，但这并不意味着它是所有学习的正确工具。然而，当响片是正确的工具时，它可以修复师生关系中最有害的部分之一。当学生开始关心获得表扬和避免批评，而不是学习本身时。如果学生想要反馈胜过想要掌握技能，那么你就会开始看到事情出错。你知道，有些学生为了得到老师的认可而不择手段，无论这是否有助于他们掌握材料。
They're not there to get good at math, they're there to get smiles from the teacher. And if the teacher is less than perfectly calibrated, it's going to turn out that the things that get smiles from the teacher and the things that actually produce understanding of math are not the same things. One of the reasons clickers might work is that they tap into a very human desire, the desire to explore. What the clicker does is say, go ahead, try and do this task, and if you succeed, I'll let you know. If you don't succeed, well, no big deal. Try again. This approach to learning is a little like playing a video game.
他们不是为了学好数学，而是为了得到老师的微笑。如果老师的评价标准不够完美，那么那些能获得老师微笑的事情和那些真正能产生数学理解的事情就不会是同一回事。响片可能有效的原因之一是它们利用了一种非常人性化的欲望，即探索的欲望。响片所做的是说，去吧，尝试完成这个任务，如果你成功了，我会让你知道。如果你没成功，也没关系。再试一次。这种学习方法有点像玩电子游戏。
You start off knowing almost nothing about what works. You're in an alien, unfamiliar world. At first you don't know which door opens to the dragon, which to the gold, but if you get it wrong, you simply restart the game. In time, you get better. Clicker training like a video game is all about discovery. When you succeed, that click tells you, okay, move on to the next step, to the next level. Not all learning can be gamified, and not all learning can be broken down into a series of steps.
你开始时几乎不知道什么有效。你身处一个陌生的、不熟悉的世界。起初你不知道哪扇门通向龙，哪扇门通向金子，但如果你做错了，你只需重新开始游戏。久而久之，你会变得更好。响片训练就像电子游戏一样，全是关于发现。当你成功时，那声响片告诉你，好的，进入下一步，进入下一个关卡。并非所有的学习都可以游戏化，也并非所有的学习都可以分解成一系列步骤。
But the clicker reminds us that sometimes the best way to help people learn is to get out of the way, and let them discover the gold behind the door. This week's show was produced by Jenny Schmidt and Thomas Liu. It was edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Paath Shah, Reyna Cohen, Laura Quarelle, Kat Chuknecht and Lushikwaba. Our unsung heroes this week are the members of NPR's training team. They recently put together a three-day training paloza. Members of our team took part in sessions
但响片提醒我们，有时帮助人们学习的最好方法是避开，让他们发现门后的金子。本周的节目由珍妮·施密特和托马斯·刘制作。由塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括帕斯·沙阿、雷娜·科恩、劳拉·夸雷尔、凯特·楚克内希特和卢希克瓦巴。我们本周的无名英雄是NPR培训团队的成员。他们最近组织了一场为期三天的培训盛会。我们团队的成员参加了
on everything from interviewing techniques to design thinking. A big thank you to the training team for organizing an event that allowed us to learn new things and to think about the work we're already doing in new ways. One last thing before we go. We're working on an episode about something that many people think about, but rarely discuss with others. Revenge. Have you ever been wronged in a way that made you seek revenge against the wrong door?
从采访技巧到设计思维的各种课程。非常感谢培训团队组织了这次活动，让我们能够学习新事物，并以新的方式思考我们正在做的工作。在离开之前还有最后一件事。我们正在制作一集关于许多人会想到，但很少与他人讨论的话题。复仇。你是否曾经受到过某种不公正的对待，让你寻求对加害者进行报复？
Maybe a partner who cheated on you, or friend who betrayed your trust, a mentor or financial advisor who led you astray. If you tried to avenge yourself and would be interested in sharing your story in an upcoming episode, please record your story on your phone and email it to us at HiddenBrain at NPR.org. Include your full name and phone number and use the subject line Revenge.
也许是一个欺骗你的伴侣，或者背叛你信任的朋友，一个误导你的导师或财务顾问。如果你尝试过复仇，并且有兴趣在即将到来的一集中分享你的故事，请在手机上录下你的故事并发送电子邮件至HiddenBrain@npr.org。请附上你的全名和电话号码，并使用主题行“复仇”。
Again, that's HiddenBrain at NPR.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. hidden brain at npr.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再说一遍，是HiddenBrain@npr.org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。hidden brain at npr.org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。